und versuchen wir etwas die Lage zu
sortieren mit Professor Carlo Masala von
der Universität der Bundeswehr guten
Abend Herr Marsala schönen guten Abend
Frau Slomka ja das sind ja relativ so
unterschiedliche Informationen die jetzt
reinkommen den letzten Tagen saß erstmal
nicht gut aus für die Offensivaktion der
Ukraine und jetzt kommen aber
Erfolgsmeldungen wie es so insgesamt
ihre Einschätzung es ist alles schwer
einzuschätzen aufgrund der Tatsache dass
die Ukraine selber
letzten Endes keine Informationen
rausgeben die Russen sehr viel
Propaganda bereiten aber was wir sehen
sind einfach jetzt strukturiertere
Angriffe an verschiedenen Stellen auf
der gesamten Front es gibt doch einige
Durchbrüche also ich glaube seit gestern
sind sie in novas Hilker zum Beispiel 22
Quadratkilometer ist Russisch irgendwas
russisch Übersetzungen befreit worden es
gibt jetzt Nachrichten über die
Zerstörung der
hauptverbindungseisenbahnlinie zwischen
der Krim und melittopol also das heißt
die ersten Erfolge sind zu sehen aber es
geht diese Offensive wird lange one sie
wird sehr blutig werden und man sollte
keine zu schnellen Erfolge erwarten also
wenn sich das bestätigen würde dass
diese hauptbahnlinie durchbrochen wäre
der die südlichen Fronten mit der Krim
verbindet wer das wie wichtig wäre das
das ist schon extrem wichtig weil es die
hauptversorgungslinie für die Krim ist
für das russische Militär auf der Krim
und ist die Hosen haben noch andere
Möglichkeiten die krimen weiterhin zu
versorgen aber es ist ein Teil dieser
Strategie die Krim von der Logistik
abzuschneiden und damit dafür zu sorgen
dass sozusagen die die russische Front
auf der Krim kollabieren könnte
potentiell also wenn das sich wirklich
bestätigt dass diese Eisenbahnlinie
gestört wurde durch ukrainische
Spezialkräfte dann ist das ein großer
Erfolg der Ukraine soweit gehört aber
auch dass wir zerstörte Leoparden
gesehen haben das sind dann auch keine
Bilder die man insbesondere im Westen
der dieses Gerät geliefert hat gern
sieht
das ist in der Tat richtig aber dazu
muss man ganz einfach auch sagen es ist
Krieg und dem Krieg werden Geräte
zerstört die Ukraine hat das Problem
dass sie angreift und sie hat nicht
sozusagen die ausreichende
personenstärkung anzugreifen man redet
ja immer laut Lehrbuch von drei oder
vier zu eins Überlegenheit die hat die
Ukraine nicht die russischen Verteidiger
haben es wesentlich einfacher sich zu
verteidigen und die Wahrheit die zum
Krieg gehört bei solchen Angriffen geht
Gerät kaputt die gute Nachricht ist aber
das aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach das
was wir hören niemand der in diesen Leos
oder Bradley saß durch diese Angriffe
gestorben ist und das zeigt wie wichtig
modernes westliches Gerät mit guter
Panzerung für die ukrainischen Soldaten
bei dieser Offensive ist man möchte sich
nicht ausmachen was die Ukraine damit
letzten Herbst hätten anfangen können
als die Russen noch nicht alles verdient
hatten und sich so tief eingegraben und
so viele Panzersperren aufgebaut hatten
das ist in der Tat richtig also wenn
dieses Gerät schon im Sommer geliefert
worden wäre wären die ukrainischen
Erfolge gewesen nicht größer geworden
jetzt hatte die Russische Föderation 4 5
Monate Zeit ihre Verteidigungsstellungen
auszubauen und das hat sie wirklich sehr
intensiv gemacht
ein anderes Thema das aber natürlich
auch in einem engen Zusammenhang
letztendlich damit steht er Defender
diese große luftübung die morgen am
Himmel über Deutschland abgehalten wird
von insgesamt 25 teilnehmenden Nationen
was ist eigentlich der tiefere Sinn und
Zweck dieser Übung kann man das kurz
zusammenfassen ja ich glaube der tiefere
Sinn und Zweck dieser Übung das sind
drei Sachen das eine ist zu zeigen wie
schnell amerikanische Flugzeuge sind ja
über 100 amerikanische Flugzeuge daran
teil wie schnell die von den USA nach
Europa verlegt werden können früher
waren diese große Übungen der Gestalt
dass das amerikanische Gerät hier war
jetzt kommt es aus den USA rüber das ist
eine das zweite ist es soll natürlich
zeigen nicht nur train as you fight also
trainiere so wie du kämpfen wirst
sondern auch Training way you fight also
trainiere dort wo du kämpfen wirst das
dient der Verteidigung ist der
rhetoriums der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und das dritte ist
Deutschland ist ja die logistische
Drehscheibe bei sämtlichen Operationen
die im Rahmen von Landes und
bundesverteidigung erfolgen werden und
die wird natürlich auch getestet wie gut
läuft auch diese Verlegung wie gut läuft
das hier in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ab und daraus kann man
Lehren dann für den Ernstfall ziehen
interessant ist ja dass diese
verlegeübung darum geht es dann ja im
Wesentlichen schon 2018 anscheinend
geplant war also es ist jetzt nicht im
Folge des Krieges plötzlich entschieden
aber soll ja wohl trotzdem ein
deutliches Signal Richtung Moskau sein
also sie wurde 2018 geplant und wurde
2018 schon für 2023 geplant also von
daher sozusagen das ist das richtige
Datum das jetzt dieser Krieg dazwischen
kommt ist natürlich ich sag mal
willkommen weil man jetzt ein sehr
deutliches Signal an die Russische
Föderation in abschrecken der Wirkung
zeigen kann weil man zeigt was man alles
im im Bereich des Luftkampf machen kann
für das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
Tim Krüger ist für uns in der Region
saporisia dicht hinter der Front und hat
mit Bewohnern gesprochen die dort noch
aushalten
wir sind auf dem Weg Richtung ulrichev
ein Ordner der Front die Zerstörung ist
fast überall sichtbar seit Monaten wird
ulriche beschossen in den vergangenen
Tagen aber sollen die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte südlich Gegenangriffe
gestartet haben der gefechtslamm sei
viel lauter sagt lubov jarowa die Chefin
des Versorgungszentrums
wir haben das Gefühl dass der große Sieg
kommt aber in der Stadt ist es viel
unsicherer geworden
gestern erst ist dieses Haus durch einen
Angriff zerstört worden ein Ehepaar
starb dabei ist die Front hier noch rund
10 km entfernt im nächsten Ort der
Hirsch treffen wir uns mit der
Bürgermeisterin Irina contra und wieso
oft in den vergangenen Tagen
Detonationen
sie erzählt uns das von den ehemals 5000
Einwohnern noch einige hundert geblieben
sind auch jetzt da die Ukraine in die
Offensive gegangen ist
[Musik]
wir haben Angst aber auch Hoffnung wir
ertragen das wir werden uns im Keller
verstecken aber wir halten durch denn
wir hoffen sehr auf unseren Sieg wir
hoffen dass wir den Aggressor von
unserem ukrainischen Land vertreiben
wir fahren in einen anderen Ortsteil der
nur noch vier Kilometer von der Front
entfernt ist der Diana Gallagher ist
Mathematiklehrerin an der Schule hier
Unterricht findet schon seit den ersten
Kriegswochen nicht mehr statt die
Klassenzimmer sind zu Lagerräumen für
Hilfsgüter umfunktioniert worden sie
hoffen hier sehr auf die Ukraine
Matratzen Decken Wasserbehälter
Hygienemittel wir bereiten alles für die
Befreiung vor denn vier Dörfer unserer
Gemeinde sind besetzt falls sie befreit
werden dann kommen die Menschen zurück
und wir müssen ihnen helfen
sie gehören zu den wenigen die all die
Krieg smonate hier ausgehart haben sie
hoffen dass diese Zeit bald vorbei ist
wir wollen das all unsere Einwohner
zurückkommen die weggegangen sind unser
Örtchen ist sehr schön
ob es nun schon die erwartete große
Ukraine Offensive ist oder nicht die
Menschen nah der Front hoffen dass Sie
schon bald wieder in Frieden leben
können